[Musique]
1810 La Redoute à Saint-Denis bien
connue aujourd'hui comme stade fut en
180 le théâtre de violent combat la
Révolution française est ACC compagné de
guerres en Europe mais aussi dans le
monde
colonial à partir de 1803 les Anglais
prennent le contrôle de tout l'océan
Indien Bourbon devenu la Réunion puis
l'île Bonaparte n'y échappe pas après
quelques tentatives d'incursion à
Saint-Paul puis à Saint-Gilles et enfin
à sain- Rose les Anglais lancent leur
assaut le 7 juillet 1810 armé de 23
navires et 3600 hommes il débarque à la
Grande Chaloupe et à Sainte-Marie pour
prendre Saint-Denis en tenaille dirigé
par le colonel brunoto de saintesusanne
les Français se replient sur le fortin
de La Redoute moins nombreux et mal armé
certains livrent un combat au corps à
corps et ils perdent la vie comme améé
Patu de Rosemond les Français se rendent
le 9 juillet les Anglais s'emparent
ensuite de Maurice en décembre Bourbon
est rendu à la France en 1815 tandis que
lilsur reste britannique jusqu'à son
indépendance en
1968 seul le mausolé de Corbette à la
marine de Sainte-Rose et deux mausolées
à La Redoute témoignent encore de la
période anglaise dans notre île 1810
l'île de la Réunion devient
[Musique]
anglaise